this is not the size I usually have this
is crazy this is actually regular size
I'm just very small hi I'm Quinta
Brunson and these are my 10 Essentials
[Music]
My First Essential is my cell phone how
could it not be I need it for everything
I need it to make phone calls I needed
to read emails I needed to text message
I needed to read scripts I was using it
earlier today to edit a script on final
draft it got broken last week I'm not
sure if you guys could see it's like
cracked it has like cracks and stuff in
it because I went to an Eagles game and
it fell and broke I don't use a case
because I don't feel like I need to says
the person who broke her phone last week
but that's okay I think it tells the
story until it completely just falls
apart I'm going to just rock out with it
on the back is a collection of all the
stickers on Friday the 30d Frankie on
our show she gives out stickers and so
this is a collection of every sticker
that's been given out it's a mess it's
disgusting and I think I'm superstitious
about it right now because I don't want
to remove them until we finish filming
the season so my phone it carries a lot
what's this you say a plant no no no
it's a diffuser I started getting into
diffusers because at Warner Brothers we
can't have open Flames but now I can't
live without it I it's the first thing I
do when I get into work in the morning I
get on set at like 5 30 and it's part of
my ritual to start my diffuser get a
good smell fresh smell going and go on
with my day and everyone's like where's
that great smell coming from you have
such a great array of plants in your
room like well one of them is the one
emitting that spell
you all saw the diffuser you can't have
the diffuser without some essential oils
these are my two favorite smells
eucalyptus
and lavender they just work well
together they work well on their own
these are the two ogs they know what
they're doing you don't really have to
mess with them too much they're going to
make your room and your house smell
amazing you'll be calm yet invigorated I
can't live without the diffuser so I
can't live without the oils to go in the
diffuser my next essential is sunglasses
I really cannot leave the house without
them and I feel like every time I do
it's a mistake I really like
this shape and I like that they're just
like dark you really they're like tinted
you can't get in there they're like the
drug dealer carve sunglasses you know
you don't know what's going on back
there it could be Quinta you know when
Superman and you're like no one everyone
knows that's Clark can't they don't
people really don't know when you put
glasses on anyone see Maverick top gun
Maverick I want to look like that I
think these help me feel like that this
is a portable speaker this is an
essential for me I carry a portable
speaker almost everywhere and when I
don't I regret it like when you go to a
hotel and you think they're going to
have a speaker so you don't bring yours
and then they don't have a speaker I
really hate listening to music on a
phone especially lately I've needed to
listen to Beyonce's album every day I'm
sorry and I'm not listening to that on
the phone that's not the way she
intended it it's not the way God
intended it I'm gonna listen to it on a
speaker but normally it'll be a mix of
like Stevie Wonder the band the internet
Thundercat Doja cat because I just think
she's fun fun vibe a lot of Aretha Frank
Franklin older Erica Badu that's
typically what a morning is my MacBook
on it I write scripts on it I had a love
affair with the MacBook in high school
you remember they had the photo booth
and everyone was so hyped about that
that's when you know all the other girls
were done Dell HP once that photo booth
came out
that was a game changer and then I got
really into iMovie like editing on
iMovie and so it just became important
to me and then all through college when
I got enough money to buy my own MacBook
that that was significant for me and I
haven't been without one since I'm the
annoying person who brings out their
computer at a nice restaurant and then
the person comes over and says excuse me
ma'am can you put that away please and
I'm like I'm spending 400 on a croissant
I'm gonna take my computer out
my next essential is Fiji Water not to
say I'm bougie but I think Fiji Water is
the best water first time I got my hands
on some Fiji I said this yeah it tastes
like it came straight from Fiji it's
just a soft tasting water and if I have
my choice like when I have a rider and
they ask me what I want I say Fiji Water
I think it's the only really bougie
thing about me
I gotta have coffee I wish I was better
than this I wish I could quit coffee but
I'm not there yet I tried to be a tea
person it's just not me I love to have
coffee in the morning it's a part of
that ritual diffuser coffee it's really
necessary I like making coffee too when
I'm not at work and just grabbing one I
really enjoy the process of making a
single cup of coffee only one cup I
can't do more than one I'm not one of
those people I won't go to sleep until
like two o'clock in the morning lip
gloss love lip gloss always have always
will loved it since I was a child it's
just the best way to make it look like
you've done something put on some makeup
that you care about your face and you
care about your appearance this one is
one of the best in the business Rihanna
did her thing with this one she just did
I'm not married to any lip gloss I'm not
agnostic there's so many Brands I love
so many different shades and colors I
just love them all if I put nothing else
on I will put on lip gloss to get out of
the door in the morning and I just
needed in my purse at all times
my last essential I'm actually wearing
right now there are my Hoops I love hoop
earrings and I love gold hoop earrings
only gold two I don't really wear silver
I just love what they do to me they make
me feel beautiful they make me feel
connected to my roots they make me feel
like the girl that I always was and
always will be it's very rare you'll see
me outside the house without earrings if
you do just know I'm having a busy day
maybe a hard day because I didn't get to
put earrings on it's like the thing I
just do not leave the house without
foreign